it's a six-week residential program here
one of the pre-college offerings here on
Carnegie Mellon's campus and it is
really designed to enhance the profile
of underrepresented minority students
interested in math and science and
others who are interested in math and
science and to hopefully give them the
skills and the exposure that will be
necessary for them to enroll in
comparable schools and Carnegie Mellon
I think what makes our program unique is
the fact that we're looking at the good
student we're they they have some
concerns academically but we're trying
to fill those gaps and create a better
student so our motto is making good
students excellent
so SAT and the actr
oftentimes the the scores on those
particular tests sometimes are
problematic for this population of
students and they're they're good
students and they're their high school
transcripts suggests that they you know
they have a set of skills but they can't
figure out how to do real to really
master the test so that's a critical
piece of our curricula is we
we we have not only the academic
curriculum but we have hands-on
engineering and science projects in fact
this year we have the largest number of
projects that we've ever had we have 12
projects that the students will be
engaging in we have a project in rocket
engineering and it's really talking
about the physics that's involved in
producing a rocket of a project and
civil engineering where they're talking
about building bridges and they're going
around in Pittsburgh and looking at some
of the bridges we have here in the city
we've had over 800 students who've gone
through the program over the 10 years we
have 83 who enrolled here at Carnegie
Mellon and the largest percentage of
them are in the engineering and and
science colleges I think success comes
in lots of different ways and but I do
think we've been successful